gottardo all and more 21 the injunction of
about four decades of debates and being
treated and cured
I'm helena silva from abbott and you were a
resident of today's event
the seminar is to see the senate and those
faced by the ldu cut and pressured
to put down with our  errors
to find out more about the routine we guys
check our website
so let's start the action before we
start I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
in kogelo to participate by raising the number
of questions you want at any
time
during the presentation to  do you can
click on the azteca chan box and click without
before the end of the presentation we will
answer all the questions
for which there is time if you have
difficulties viewing the presentation obsession
click on the support tab located in
the upper right corner of the
presentation window or report your
difficulties  by clicking on the nursery box
located on the far left of the
screen
this educational presentation
offers  ce continuing education credits
by your voice that click on the
education pre bis corner located in the
regional upper right corner of the
presentation and follow the process to
obtain your credits
so now present our constant
professor doctor poor lunches
will only take care of teaches at the university of
lisbon at the hospital  from santa maria som
e tato marino practices medicine since 1962 he
has a doctorate in astrology in 2002 he is
head of service at the department of
the hepatology anthology at hospital santa
maria doctor rui tato marino is very active in
numerous national and international professional societies he
was president pode que exporta  Fétal Landim
between 2013 and 2015 is vice-
president of the Portuguese society of
gastroenterology was in vai e provir
chambord between 2007 and 2010 elo
when the party of the end of the
rise sesi is held and he is also an elected member of the
general assembly of the antp in castal do
team  at the top and tato marino was the
editor-in-chief of portuguese america and
t  in addition to the restructuring of technology
the contributions of her imagination she
includes the publication of more than 93
articles in the promise and other medical publications that are a
reference in her area of ​​her
home she organized more than twenty-four
meetings including the festive week the
national congress of technologies 2017
has  had in the invitations for speakers
in national and international finals for
a more complete biography of our
continent with his biography in the
upper white part of the itapemirim river can
then start his presentation
voted all love name is rui marino
imagined to thank is a to talk
here share some  moments of our
life we ​​learn from each other and
above all climbing stairs and even
fleeing liked santa Marinha do google
is the largest hospital in the country and that we are going to
address today it is only four decades almost
mother and dry on the subject of the executive
this reason for being here  treating and curing
are four decades that we will explain
in about a half  the time but this failed in
bids given us is that he achieved it in
my work has been is dedicated to the
son of god a lot of seal from the
specialized internet site how to leave each
story an organ to the mystical magician is at the
same time and is perhaps  for the service
where they manage to work in all those
who influenced him
is the son it was the best year of choice
in this sense since 1989 it is
practically 30 years of coming every
day not only in consultation but in the
information and intensive care
is what we have been dealing with  with liver patients
with this liver virus and it will not assume
to produce which is unique in the country and has had
nine
beds for 30 years and has
international certification by the European body and even
the day we were selected to be an
international training center by
the European Union being that  the day and
we are also capable of training people about
his reign inside the kitchen let's say
like that end I'm not superman I didn't
know how to overcome the same month of the river
v  red
both the person wants to stay virtually
and having the obligation to know a lot
about diseases are very complex and are
entering more directly into our
subject that I want to convey at the end of
this greater place is to understand the
importance of the laboratory and that is the
objectives of the world organization  health
for the enlightenment of the hepatitis c virus
we already have a disease that is practically
asymptomatic and have known the recent
advances and that are many
in the country's recommendations from the claws that
support the left objective for 2030
that the elimination of the video to warm up and
then we try in the  in order to describe
some simplified processes we have to
eliminate the bureaucracy that there is a lot and
what they look at me is the clinical and
laboratory diagnosis is not even going down and that basically
we have access to our care at this
moment that is curative to eliminate
the hepatitis c virus that we have some  very
powerful is at this moment is I chose
these three letters the tt is extra is the
enf  renting in public notice again
spreads like
a single year we have now
achieved are the cure of a terrible disease it
is a healthy war it is an agreement
that has a video that is routined with
bacon it is just a simple analysis that is
positive but it is a video that is
working as it is with who is the
hepatocellular carcinoma that we
expect will increase in the next 30 years and
that's allow means that it is possible to
perfectly identify
is the worst if that means therefore that
no one will be obliged to all those
who are coming to me is the hospital  but we
saw the training I think we did today in the
market in lisbon is to treat and
nowadays the vast majority of treatments
the sanction is 2 months is 56 days
is what is spectacular because we manage to
finish a book many times it was
there 30 40 50  years but in two months we
managed to capture it and then come back to
it however it is a very
simplified process we can test it again
only three months or six months later
the end of the treatment and we know that nowadays the
resource is practically close
to 100% it
is in a first to a first wave of
we gain the first line in
growing
we still have excellent medicines
allows almost gaaal 100% so it will be
a test is being treated then return to
test in this process but if it stays pt it's
been practically 40 years and I'll
explain why it's standard for being created -
the video was only discovered in 39 but let's
see that it's very curious to have
to speak in 34 and prologic portugal
74 hours presented a  evolution and I
think in the field of producing ica on campus
party and 74 market that is because it
is the first year
in which the class is someone says that there seems to
be a hepatitis c virus this is
a complicated process the history of
men is  made of small moments of
years - I had the city is experiencing
this great evolution of medicine the
doctors had of course we started
curiously at the same time it was
founded  the unit will produce consul
also produced and we did the first
tests for hepatitis c is to spend four
months of witness identifying the video
also extinct do the first test
to identify the patients that
we thought were on a bus that
were alive but the first tests
appear  the article is five pages with
two articles published
the international one and we continue only the
embroidery called being the technician we did it
soon we went to do tests
unless we have a serum to keep it and
identify, for example,
drug users that 80% were
affected or  whatever we have known for over 30
years
I know that we only spend consequences
anne who faced drug addicts
and we realized that they did because they passed if
many things
we started to go to the media at
this moment we live in 4 for the
front pages of news with the 96
who believed in us
20 years ago in 97 and soap that could say
it was a public health problem a
color  they're going to fix it with biologists and
duck that both in the treatments but
easier to do always the fear of the
spectrum having to take it today, right person
several things until we arrive are
articles published in the in the great
international conquest she is not in the
world that the  imam union was shown in the
state we live in will not convert
seven percent of people of color at
will a lot of personal things
worth keeping but let's go directly through what
it means to have a son of the
river disease it is an extremely complex disease
I would say with  the province of ghazni
pathologist is s rosa tie who is
represented here this son all
trained at the center of these works in this
thread cycle and we can say that in
portugal there are 30 40 percent of
portuguese people infected with hepatitis c
have cirrhosis and cirrhosis means the risk
and  road urbanism that I'm going to
quantify and then new in the background the
hepatologist's practice is clinical from
the social and human point of view it is very
intense  eressante is very good not giving you
since people who have
completely asymptomatic diseases serious similarities
I do said pink already compensated without
complications for example you take the
ache that it is the field of the wire is very
competitive and live or die of the
liver transplant
the team is also  very cool is the
practice of palliative care and many
times even where we are focused on
ending the sick family
the end is near in which they helped them to
pass this complicated phase of life
lately hepatitis if we know
one of the big problems is the virus
entering the organism for the first time, the
vast majority after the MPT and PTM
ask how many times it is asymptomatic
or go to chronic
liver cirrhosis the more time passes the greater the
risk of it percent in portugal this
year is it around 30 to 40% and in which  you have
cirrhosis the risk of turning it into a
hepatocellular carcinoma help between one of
course there is always a year i.e. another
year goes by very quickly  between and up to 10
years of our life years I usually say
that after ten years within 40
percent of our patients have the son's field and
we started talking in the
message that being chronic is a
curable disease several years ago when  one of the
first presidents of the association of the
father pastor of the son of the most important thing is
how to say that the disease was curable two
is a lot and this topic was just a lot and
I'm there to start thinking about it but they
cured
it means for example to do a
treatment that  we do it today with the
new treatments and after six months
three months of treatment or and then the
surveillance and after the treatment
we know what it's like to have
the video for the rest of your life those who don't
have this rose cure is complete for  the
evolution to cirrhosis will stop the
revolution for whom the child starts another one
at the beginning of the cycle is 7484 as
some of us know it was the function is in portugal it is
very curious and in the end this in this type
of cultural incentive  author is the price on
an international visit the big
favorite lancet says that there would be the
video called if for 15 years it
didn't catch on is it's a video with a crash I started
to deal with when I started it's side by side
in 74 to a researcher who already spoke about
this  question 5 is still
very curious is the hepatitis c virus
started to be continuous it is few and few
attacked it mined with 1 89 it
was a bad year it was also stolen a
historic year and already at that time it
started on the way they identified the virus
i  I made another moment in 2002 and it was
very curious at that time I already knew
perfectly what the virus's masters
were there was no doubt in it 10 well
contained there were dozens of articles
about what is no less
colorful about its activity
I was already  it was hoped that in the future,
later on, eventually it would be necessary to
steal it like that, no,
it will not appear in the
near future but much was already known about
the video that was much more serious it was by
chance that  the virus was identified later
in 1989 and later in 2014 and it cures
most of the patients was one of the
most spectacular measures of our
life as doctors at a time
when in portugal there was a lot of talk about the price
of medicines because we used all the
friendly attachments  in boston what
the doctors said no the 14 in boston gave
all the fluids everyone was happy and
events also because we have a reserve a
medicine it cured almost all
cases of hepatitis for that the old ones
in which we
we participated 12 published in new
england as  the room with 7 at the
time the number of 250 patients only did not
cure 11 we could that way in a good
way once I showed you are amy how to
say that gold
the treatment is effective it does not exist in
practice it is to cure almost all patients
an infection conflict by  william for
those who are not there who represented one of the
articles in which the space already in 2014 all
the works were carried out in 2013
clinical trials that we believe we are grateful for
I really liked us in our center and
practically 97 new groups 99 4% of
our patients cure a disease and museum
had 30 40 years ago in 12 of the brothers
in three months it
was a moment of great happiness
for many a patient I remember this
fight with three ends is happiness she
shared with me
the beginning of the course and she really
tried she was almost practically blind
in her eye is one of the manifestations to be
prepared because judgment draws and you are not
just a son and she wanted to share this
moment with me finally thinking about the  your
three children - we live here the same sign
of resumption of the first pill that
will remain for training
let's say it's ua the success story
in part of that time as we did in
relation to the genotype 1 that I
started to be taken in 86
also takes the  meetings that we
discussed to the point of exhaustion effectiveness 556
try secondary and today I
patrol there is almost no
public discussion practically stayed in all
patients and at the moment the  s
national data in the trials
the website is the
real-life clinical use data as we call it and the
trials with 30 points and it was close
to my dreams in another aspect also
changed radically was that we stopped
being aggressive consensus on the huge
with  our treatments with the
treatments are felix is ​​not only in the phase
before the treatment we concluded the iraq
must observe at each stage
many of them do not even arrive at our
consultations and they were crowded with a
growth of ours who had seen
this and we are agents in my hands my
son I didn't do a thousand more and oxygen from the
marriage with complications
nobody likes to waste time it's a
needle in a
we practically ended it
because we have an hour nowadays they
point out ultrasound called son I want
you to allow two minutes where we
substantial newspaper and then we finish the
that we have done for many years with
see here I think the injections of
frank infant food with darium is
often  which was used for six
months a year national
infarmed fortunately I have a record of
all the treatments used with these new
treatments we have already treated them already cured
[Music]
more than 20 thousand people are those who
reached the end
96 then cured which is very interesting
because in all  that's right the first
thing we did is at the
international level the treaty of this virus and
eliminating this view is only because of negative manaus
the physical burden is also to calm that
person who is going to have a disease that can
be deadly that is contagious that can
transmit to others  We don't know if it's going to
provoke in the field we're going to do it
from a mental point of view social point of view
how the executive just ceases to be
infectious from uncertainty the stigma is having
a pop video infected the psoe while
married I don't know
how he didn't say the woman had  and
even according to the objectives of the role of a
soldier in são miguel sou sanctioned by
the world health organization we managed to
achieve mental and physical well-being
social and undermining ours before
detonation indicates less oral medications we
published the article also an
international magazine over the years
we have been correcting the benefits of
moisture
this virus and it is since so much by
negative charge 0 brutal effectiveness a bride
will use the analysis of the threads
in  several cases disappears pink
according to noé very advanced disappears
azores the phase that is sick as i have
seen it was already in a phase where they thought
they were on the
liver transplant list leaving the list
a third of the patients very advanced
still the list disappears the risk  of
sexual transmission
disappears the risk of transmission
at Christmas time is some some
insurers manage to even
reduce premier and in the south of the benefits
and in practical terms to pass on to the
public that the reason is value and
horses and at this moment carrying out
anticancer treatments do not  had an
agreement is more effective in another sink goes
[Music]
so its prevention until co  comparing this one
is not even for the cultivable people
when we cross the day that there was a
consultation with 35 elements it is continued
dehumanizes democracies humanizing the
teams know but sometimes above the
messages for 11 years
we roemos a few years ago wanted to
do that only spoke the  two
teams needed lewis a lot before that
if we advance to the level there in
completing with trying to deal with people
who are suffering we have an obligation to
help and we are dealing with people at
greater risk
despite the disease not having symptoms are
options that are in  risk the north and what
was shown
in this positive is that after eliminating
the virus we managed to reduce the risk of
death is presented here by bath is
that it exerted a new virus but those in
which it does not light up production is fast
at the end of the year  2 years the risk is
increasing so much we see that there is a
pathological urgency illuminated this virus
at and in time the first of our understanding
we will publish  it was also a few
years ago to show that this treatment
during a cosmetic and clicked
hear once again greater points of 40
the risk of evolution of the child cold to the
market in the same more advanced phases
of silva rosa in the so-called
decompensated phase is incredible we have that the
patients have almost no more than 11 days
between them and other complications that a
third of these patients cause
mortality such as esophageal seproturs
like 50 patients die keeping
pizzolio and at the moment we are
managing to reduce to almost zero the risk
in the us of following these complications  and
when it looks from the xix when they appear
sad the horizontal structure bands that
stop that when faced in this graph
death curve or survival curve
is equal to that of the fields
even if it is not in the time phase with
many times as it is a
malignant disease by its behavior  it is in
terms of a threat and a disease as
I will demonstrate it is very treacherous
very silent with which they talk about the
echo  nomia cearense osas and we have disease
the use
and time of the son that appear to us
is already a very advanced stage in a
long time has passed sometimes a few years without
symptoms
this was a boy aged 50 by
chance it was milsinho a few years ago and
that seems to me one day with manaus a tie
if positive that I knew it was
many years old and with a tumor practically on the
wire it practically creates a
hepatocellular carcinoma and it could have been
avoided if we had
done the treatment a few years ago it's a santana said it
becomes when  is that we are going to respect and
there is something that could be a
rational infection and not transformed
everyone wanted to pass through the hands of the
principal's
son  wii
is anything and we will get
the biological response after the treatment [Music] that is after the
humiliation with the hiv treatment
three months later  which is the main
the main point for us we know the
treatment should stay if I was not
negative in 23 months the person was
included that the whole life - that comes back to
face
then how to make the diagnosis
one of the main messages 10 in this
minute passed 16  hours a test is
intended to be once in a lifetime it's not
too much
to ask take the da silva test also the
recommendation my colleagues from infectious
did not have it however if not every day
everyone
can the portuguese will now do
it don't do it at least once more in the
life and it is a very simple test is that the
antibody from the video of 25 before gas and
eventually we will not talk about it
if you want to join you can join the
practical one in time there
is a vaccine it is also a stage disease but do a test
once in a week  people's lives and not
rest assured their texts are positive and it
's not intense but it doesn't mean that the
person has already faced it but the step will
be to load the executive's dna without
however we have  two tests and also when
will the outbreaks be free and that the brain in the
video of hepatitis c is to leave the position in
drug users just find out
that the antibody is positive a
quarter of people
do not have active books also
probably could have been a
spontaneous cure  and we know that
circulatory part in about 20 fundamentals
and 25% of the fields
is currently in portugal is a large
percentage of today face them i
belong to drug users in
us1 it passed within a few years but i
want to escape very dignified zara our
knowledge  and in many
completed cases people who consumed
some drugs in the last year had
used to catch a tie that if nowadays they
are clients big companies international level
some ministers so much we see
each other late thematizing each other because
we all did some things we
learned is more taboo  in many of these
people they have the same partner
because of the biopsy this is the
ap  air called fibroscan that goes
a nice kombi let's say and we
in two minutes
it's a system similar to an
ultrasound and it managed to go up just think
pink you can't see it close up may have if
we even had it there, right there isn't
so an exam that goes too
the movement at an
international level in the
past just to have an idea in the chart
[Music]
was identified and that all types of
books typical personal
slave-like software genotype 1 the euro2000 of
all time and it was also a great
advance and in the country  what we have today is
for everyone and not types of treatments
409 just two months which is fantastic
with this we are going to achieve one of the great
objectives of the world
health organization which will be not 2030
so much here 12 years ago
the problem of hepatitis c with a  problem
more october that worldwide is
saying the first oncogenic virus that
man can light up when he is cured there
the cdc of the plant says no it was not
creative of hepatitis c and  with that we will be
able to reduce it so we can
be
cold and enjoy it in a dream possible
that we can manage to treat yanam only
those who are in a more serious phase but
a little body to treat is absurd is
what we have in our our feel
trying to steal one  anti e 12 cover in
faro - that helped to resolve
something was himself not well said and
wrote this title is that the days
three years ago we can't waste
time at that moment I'm sorry about that
because the more years go by 12 years
without  being able to have more people with whom the child has
a term nowadays in
our practice which is linkedin
this means identifying the nicest people
we take care of treated as
quickly as possible
and often it is not enough to give the compress
we have to know how to absorb  Isis already has that
is when the thread so much from the point of view of doctors is
complete and the
objective is also to simplify more and
more highly effective pills
practically infant  is secondary in which they
gained weight it is because complicated from
a bureaucratic point of view that point the
components with trips to the hospital several
times with spouses proofs with 16
but we sent it very important to do
things in a simple and efficient way and
we can even dispense with the fibroscan we can
as I have  seen some countries in
europe and europe france and spain is
that i can from santarém took to the pharmacy to get
the pills
the guys their cure let's say like that also the
other philosophy that we call a thread
for so much want that is not the patients
come to us  even because some
are in prison
and we have it and also the prisons are
the two most disadvantaged groups
that even have a child they don't have money to
pay for transport but this year the
hospital the employees subscribe to a
black car that today we have the chance
to draw blood  doing a lesson this
time is only right
for afe brascan katz to get the
pills to these people and
force us to do the same  table the hospital and
take advantage of the studies are on the ground
such put there was a drop in nurses are
pharmacists new colleagues who have already
performed treatments help cure the
left wing nuno managed to continue to
have many innovations in training
if for example the col antigen hopes
that in some cases  do not come to replace the
analysis of the so-called pcf charge and check
a reaction that is complete if complex
that only happens in the hospital even if expensive
but this is undoubtedly finishing the glass
of the old car that the colon antigen
that we have is easier
no  I have you will discover tom bland the
system will be very good but it is much
cheaper and easier to use than I
thought I know that on top of that in
Portugal it is only done in the locals
instant genius of the colon
finally towards the total 150 years of
the European selection  which is the first step
for things to be disclosed has been going on
for a few years now and the size of the
world recession on and off session lights
and a panel that the former  ênnio do colo is the
marker biblical explanation of the book the
practice coping used as
we use the pc is alternative in
cases where we do not have the chance to
use the potential as much as you can
check
here in sydney also part of jamaica
time in europe developed already site  with
a very high degree of demand grown
symbolize tim is already from the glass and that is
also not only prognostic to know if
that person how much and how positive
is infected or not but also the cure
and after the treatment in this case 25
years and six months later  from the end of the
treatment
a very short time ago and they are during the
500 is in 2008 minus two months
one of the major international criticisms
for what Portuguese or
antigen authorization occurs as an alternative to ps and
not even as you can see in the graph
we have a population it's just  between very good
between the levels of the pcf of the
cut antigen is it is a goal in the end I
am determined and two aspects of the diploma
- I am very  the happy person and I give them a
piece of paper it has a curve at the end it is
a plate people I didn't know aloud
I explain that the antibody should stay in principle for the rest of
their lives because of
medical cases that they return to the ship
later they
want it there and it was positive
the antibody but it does not mean that the
video is focused
another important aspect is that those who already
have cirrhosis will have cirrhosis for life
the risk of complications goes to almost zero you
just have to do it every
six months
one of the ideas  that I had said at the
beginning that I
treated it more quickly and avoid
those people who have it yet don't have it
if we don't evolve to
cirrhosis people like it a lot
are the mother first most
important ones related to the
hepatitis c virus
we calculate place still with style and
maybe 50 thousand people
yes take the test once the friend
we doctors and other staff  only
when we are informed people do we have the
obligation to use those who don't know
whom we have a powerful weapon destroyed its
cannons many chronic diseases
also take the test because if once
from anvisa
if the text is positive then i can get
25% of the  video wasn't everything finish the
post come and that through the pc ro of the
colo antigen want manaus over 60 and
scoppitto we are treating a
chronic disease a disease with genetics not only
I see but also then if you a
curable disease practically 97%  of the
cases in which the 3% do not cure
we also have a medicine the course will
practically stop 14 3% this
is the first time in the history of
man with the possibility of illuminating
a chronic disease it is a counterpart here in
many cases it has existed for 30 40 years
how effective even superior to being human was
able to injunction and finally we are going to finish
thank you very much for your attention the
belongings and the time is greater than
the others and yes then the books
with  mo
handsome to be flame piranha duck in
which there is the body of the son of the south close to
the wire feel excluded for a
question period and sporting is thank you
once again for the attention that what
was obliged to win none i am a
communist is and asia
questions and  answers we have to see
the accounts all the pieces came up an
environmental wave only one success of the
space are the 1976 11 and tv and they
tried we requested it not be possible to
order one of us with that we
don't just do it just put it in my
opinion  is that the attacks see where you
put it against hepatitis the antiviral
is here is the problem
antónio who does it said the same thing he left without
calling again the person
automatically make your face play with the
antigen through the sky send proposing local
difference include it again styles
win  tables and some diesel at the
beginning and 25 always at two o'clock it
doesn't have the hepatitis c virus it's
cured it will also reduce the signal I've
seen people from my life  From
your pure images that I have to the
positive ones that don't mean ronaldo but
that panicked only the
positive government is and davi relations cut off by
new devices that was worth nothing
he had just been misinformed it's very useful
pacific go do it there and a lot of people
passed this one  switzerland, similar to what
exists in france, for example,
automatically makes that rich face
and soon a quarter of people don't even
need to go to the hospital and it's for their
house there was so much response that we want
to drive a car one more sense
significance and positive antibody test
obligatory public load in the same
laboratory in inhaúma preta sp and
symbol between genius and fhc and make
sure your tricolor is negative
and genius and immovable from an active infection
is the viral load sunday because it serves
for the antigen is of the colon
like me  said just talk presentation
people's room or more how one
thinks even in one's mind the hepatitis c virus
does not need to be treated just a reason
for the tr  atado who has a case of
verônica is positive
the fight is still one is an
isolated result of the calculation silos look for him m
no that doesn't make any sense
once in a lifetime doing the test happened it
was prudent for the team to always advance by hand
like carlicahn  to know your
objective not positive active infection
would also be the sound is like an
acute hepatitis
we have probable cases as an example
also the organism we have carlos
well at home and I can be negative in
bissau the cocoa show actions right in the public jail
so  if you have the symptoms in
practice the yellow eyes examined a
lot of values
we had a test for you to be negative it
can pass positive and I think it's
more convenient that she had a rich face
a couple of times to know if she's going to
be the type of real estate more  once
carlicahn is positive from the logistical point of view
let's say from the organization in the south it is one
of the complexes if we have medication is
who is that person that we were
[Music]
infe  going to the hospital complex following
consultations with the south is much easier and
our proposal is that we make the complex
close to the ex
the enlightened unemployment of the
responsible growth practice tomorrow in eighth but it
was to do the house would come in who did the
positive test in the positive
botticino test  understands that battisti can be
done on site
in 2001 we had in the market the one that enters
to make such the hotel fibrosis year he
the people who were passing by and the vol 1
logo is the proposal of the games to be
quick tests of hepatitis a small drop of
blood  we are going to do this in a
few weeks
so make the
loading and vinca process simplified
in the first sample eventually
positive and the doctors manage to carry out
the treatment have access to the treatment
practically on time
I think that at this moment when they
registered on the electronic portal that I
basically did not  I don't think they are used well,
but living there for six months 200
complicated approvals in the field doesn't make
much sense walking  ho but from the logistics organization of the
organization's strategy in
the south and south to call other professionals
like we have been doing pharmacists to
help us is to inform jen and not
focus everything on the role of the doctor
surface twitter who is in the
hospital where scheduling appointments is so
difficult  both the setting sun of the
organization are complete release it
it is and there is not a strategy it is national it
is good
the strategy for example treated
who is in the hospitals and m easy
actively easy apart from that
practical spectrum we also managed to treat
everyone and approval although in this
first number with noé does not happen in
many other hospitals
we understand that there must be a
national plan but that there are more assets
that already calmly the
budgetary situation and that would
proactively promote the tests in the field by
the hands of many other entities by the
hair  I have spent years in Portugal not having a
practice that helped to identify making
the diagnosis  and pink is a disease that
can steal the camera borrowed by
several centers by several it is the backyards
I usually admit that it has to
do with prisoners living with a lot of prison guards it
is the hospital to do an exam
now two minutes for
a patient to come to a remote island  from the azores
is to make a film spend an hour and two
minutes to make i
think we should be more diplomatic
of data more and more portuguese
klepht next year will live in a
world with fewer people faced without
ever knowing if we unite we can cross not
having a notion one  if you contaminate another
negative way in the hospital by
someone to vote for what I see is indecent
a system plus the text antibody all
makes sense obviously all the text
the positive cases do then come and a
half in the face of rica
us now when we went is  one of the
lisbon conclusions
we had 60 people with the
positive antibody of which only 30 had the
face of rich positive both the others
had cured with tania me  Before one
had been treatment and some showed
that I have done
it makes no sense to take the test because they
say the text not much car all
fifth in prison and in our understanding
so much all that once again left the
self-care in making some
final adjustments to our  audience and I love
you thanks for the invitation it was a pleasure to
be here once in itself it was publishing in the
intense front page diary
that was almost the killer of happiness
we make our portuguese
fluid after 20 years some gods
investing in currency or looking for  the cure
in portugal and us in almost 100% god is that
we got this cure for a
disease that killed the reason was the
conclusion of the mall and kicks it
's a privilege to be here inside the
cockpit of the plane and help a lot of people
suffering from a disease isn't it  just one person
on top of the wires in the passengers parents the
friends of colleagues who have a
more global vision than our voltage that
many thanks also to the
pharmaceutical industry  ica that together with
doctors constant with politicians and
bet on research and dignified consuming
treat cure and and do because this is the
main message that teaches has a
lot of common sense history like this
but I don't see in I'm all the time the
study will also be  there those signed on
this side were winning here and they always
joined us today I am one of those who
also resolved all the questions not
with the families today I don't know there
they are showing the way not yet just a
contact since it made me happy
television
another message the tacit requirement to
know animal species is the month of
may 2003 the alert function in may
arrives then such questions as are the
families in projects of the program marcos
Coelho does not want to hear the account with the
courses until next time